i'd like to welcome on to the stage now
someone we we did hear from briefly
earlier from eastern new energy from the
university over east london dr auror
julian
so um i thought it was the end of the
day
and
therefore um perhaps uh a presentation
about i don't know heat pumps wouldn't
be so welcome
and therefore what we've done is um a
little quiz
like a pop quiz except you haven't got
any
uh pints to drink i mean you could have
a pint of water if you like
it's not gonna be the same um so
this is about
how
smes can get to zero carbon so it's
quite light-hearted
um
a low level of complexity i would say so
i really encourage you to participate to
the quiz
if you have a phone you can
use
www.menti.com you can try to get this i
don't know if you're close enough you
can join another group if you like
you don't have to use your phone you can
just answer it's all about speed
there so um and also i encourage you to
do this in a group it's it's nicer isn't
it and then you get to know each other
so i'm going to give you a little bit of
time to get organized
[Music]
so there's a code which you might be
asking is three three four six six three
eight seven
everybody ready
say no if you're not ready
no
so we're gonna have a little bit of time
for those who arrive
if you want to use your phone or maybe
you can join somebody that's already
logged in
and
and help them to answer
so you need to use your phone to answer
the quiz questions
i can see at the back
are you done alex
yes
you ready
okay
so
first question
so if she's still not um joined us you
can go to mentee.com and use the code
which is three three four six six three
eight seven
uh can you yeah thank you
so you need to answer fast this is an
easy one to start with what is not an
impact of climate change pretty obvious
hopefully
rising oceans and flooding wildflyers
crazy weather disruption in the food
supply the hole in the hosen layer heat
i
waves
maybe it's not obvious i don't know
hmm
my partner got it wrong i was quite
disappointed
okay
disruption in the food supply that's
um the
the wrong answer the honey the hole in
the ozone layer
is actually the one which is not um an
impact of climate change in fact the
whole the hole in the ozone layer is
improved by climate change because
higher temperature help the reformation
of ozone
so
really climate change is all about
disruptions in meteorological events
hydrological events and climatic climate
i can't say it
climatological events
it's not really about the ozone layer
it's a separate issue
question two of three
thank you
which of the following would have would
have the biggest impact on reducing
carbon emissions
growing your own vegetables stopping
deforestation
taking all fossil fuel burning vehicles
off the road
shutting down fossil fuel power plants
or recycling all of your waste
yes that's correct
shutting down all fossil fuel power
plants
so
the sort of thing you can do about this
is first of all save energy it's pretty
obvious and then secondly adopt
renewable energy tariffs and then you
can if you are an sme or an organization
ensure that you procure
and use a procurement supply chain which
uses low carbon products or companies
question three
how much co2 emissions does a uk
resident emit per year roughly or 0.5
tons
6 tons 120 tons or three tons
per uk resident
[Music]
six tons that's correct
so
the uk's
per-person co2 mission has been reducing
um slowly in the last
say 50 years
60 years and in fact is a a level which
is um
the same as during the victorian times
roughly or previous to the material
victorian times now the thing is that
this doesn't take into account the
carbon emissions which are
produced through the production of
products which are perhaps imported from
other countries
and what we know is that there's many
countries around the world where co2
emissions are increasing at very very
accelerated rate
question four
what target for limiting global warming
was set by the international governments
at the paris conference in 2015
below 1.5
2 or 3 degrees centigrade
it's below 2. it should have been 1.5
but it is 2.
since then the ipcc has very clearly
sent the message that it should be below
1.5 degrees centigrade not two two is
too dangerous but the indication at the
time sorry this is really tiddly text
shouldn't be there um the indication at
the time that um
below
1.5 degree was preferable but the target
was set as two degrees now we are at
group 26
and you know very soon and so we're
hoping lots of good things are going to
come out of that
but there are also been been some very
useful targets which have been set up
recently uh namely in april this year
for example there's the uk has set up a
target to 78 reduction of co2 emissions
and in comparison to 1990 levels so this
is really positive
moves that have been taken
how much of the uk's carbon do smes emit
so there was a workshop which touched
this recently so perhaps you know this
already
5 8 13 or 24
hmm
it's eight percent
it's eight percent
it's not always the majority that wins
with these questions is it
so some of it is counterintuitive i did
it on purpose because i'm a bit evil
um so
it's eight percent so it's about half
roughly there's just numbers actually
vary sometimes i've seen numbers that
are a little bit um slightly higher but
it's roughly eight percent of the uk's
carbon emission um
and it sort of compares um to sm sorry
it's six percent in this graph it's
actually eight percent got this wrong
apologies
which proportions of uk's smes measure
the carbon emissions
one in five one in ten one in twenty
what do you think
oh no
that's just chance really it's one in
ten
[Laughter]
one in ten which is low enough i would
say
um
so just about one in ten uk smes measure
their their carbon emissions um
this is not this survey was not
specifying whether they were measuring
scope one two three or all of the scopes
it was just about measuring carbon
emissions um so it's very interesting
because there's various surveys which
find that smes are very interested in
improving their environmental impacts
and their co2 emissions but they found
it really difficult to actually measure
their impacts generally and to embed
sustainability strategies in their
operation
smes however are known to have the
greatest potential in reducing their
energy consumption and carbon emissions
compared to larger companies
question seven
what else could free greenhouse gas
emissions i mean there's been a lot of
mention of scope 3 green gas gas
emissions and direct carbon emissions
from electricity using buildings
indirect greenhouse gas emissions not
directly owned or controlled direct
carbon emissions from vehicles are
burning fossil fuel use or a mystery
i don't know if you can see from the
distance as well probably doesn't make
it easy
and greenhouse gas emissions not
directly owned or controlled that's
correct
the majority is right
so just a reminder scope one emissions
are direct emissions from the fuel that
you um use which got gas for example in
buildings or
the what you put in your cars that you
own um so confusion from company
vehicles would be scope one scope two
are indirect energy users for example
electricity which depends from the grid
yes so it could be also heat which is
com you know used from a district
heating system
um so this is scope 2 scope 3 are all
the other
indirect emissions so for example we
know that scope 3 includes things like
business travel
waste disposal employee committing
transportation
by contractors or the products that
you're going to purchase
and things like data
so there's a wide range of scope 3
emissions um which are more difficult to
control and also to evaluate
and there's always ways to reduce those
emissions um the fact that they're
indirect and not under direct control
don't mean that we cannot reduce those
emissions so i'll give some examples for
example business travel can be reduced
obviously through using more online
meetings
question eight
you're nearly done with the quiz
how do you scope three missions compared
to scope one and two emissions for
businesses
not just smes businesses in general
it is smaller it is twice greater
or more than five times greater than
scoped
one and two
twice greater is the majority is wrong
it's difficult questions isn't it so
it's it's five points five times roughly
and this is an estimate because really
we don't know the scope-free emissions
of all businesses but it's an
approximate
value which has been found on on the
ones where which have done the
calculations
so what can you do now if you're an sme
or if you have an organization first you
need to commit secondly measure
emissions
reduce
and put together a plan to reduce
emission comes then after that and then
finally offsetting is the last thing
you can do it's the last resort this has
been taught i think several times today
question nine is the last question
a very difficult one
will you commit to net zero by 2050
yes nope who knows
so it's a difficult question that's why
we need a lot of time here
yes that was the correct answer
so there's ways to commit i mean
certainly for for a a company you could
just have a policy
which you know should have different
targets which are timed
you can also go
if you're an sme
on the sme climate hub and commit
through that website it requires you to
disclose progress
on an annual basis
measuring carbon emissions can be quite
complex there are a plethora of tools i
currently have a phd student who's
dedicated at the moment to looking at
all the tools um that
are available in the uk to calculate
carbon emissions for smes and there's
many so um is is complicated however
there are some free tools that are very
well known like for example the carbon
trust semi carbon footprint calculator
the
tool available on climate hub
and
also if you want to calculate
the green
if you want to calculate scope 3
emission you can use the greenhouse gas
protocol
tools
then you need to establish a roadmap
in order to do that um
you can sort of first evaluate the
different um carbon emissions that you
might have and various uses of energy
direct and indirect
again a number of tools that can help
you through this process
it is important to
consider
what options you have that might be free
as a starting point
you know if you do not have any budget
perhaps this is a good way to start
doing things there's already probably
things that you're doing
and you need to recognize those
the sort of options that i have put here
are more about buildings because
buildings is my own specialty
but but there's many other things that
can be looked at
and then it's important to identify the
most cost effective options
many organizations are really keen to
have photovoltaics on the roof or
systems which might be visible but this
is not necessarily the most cost
effective option so for example led
lighting can be a very cost efficient
way to to reduce carbon emissions and
perhaps not so obvious
but the payback is really short or just
simply insulation in the roof can be
also extremely cost effective
then switching to a zero carbon tariff
can be a good way to quickly save carbon
although
i think it should be con considered as
also a last option after uh reducing
energy use um
so
the sort of discussions around which
providers should be suitable for that
purpose really regardless regales
type providers
on paper they do mean zero carbon the
truth is that they just
don't necessarily stimulate renewable
energy because simply regoes have become
so cheap because there's so much
renewable energy in the grid now
um that um it doesn't really support the
stimulation of of the you know renewable
energy new renewable energy sources
being
set up so
preferably it's better to use providers
which are buying
or building new sources of renewable
energy where possible or buying
electricity through
power purchase agreements agreements
then finally you can um offset
um so for example um
offsetting is a bit of a
difficult conversation this very
difficult point of view certainly is the
last thing to look at once you've done
all the other things
it is recommended that if you're looking
out of setting that you use
schemes that are accredited
the gold standard is very well known for
example and also supported by a number
of charities
in terms of it offsetting
renewable and energy efficiency schemes
can be really good
um tree planting
i don't want to say that tree planting
is never a good idea i think it can be a
good idea but it's so complex to have a
tree planting scheme that actually works
in the long run
that generally is not considered to be a
good option
the thing about trees is that they have
a lifespan unless they're going to stay
there for a very long time it doesn't
make sense and also a large
tree splinting scheme can be
can have a negative impact on local
population there's a number of problems
with tree planting schemes
the reds projects are about preventing
deforestation but they do not work
because simply they displace the
deforestation um to another place
um so effectively they're not really
effective and the official
offset schemes have been also
discredited
widely for example um the certificate
certified emission reduction schemes
have um have used
sort of have supported uh
decarbonization um for through
um
preventing some gases uh
to be emitted by um companies but half
of the companies that were emitting
those gases
have stopped how can i explain this
have stopped
producing these gases and reproduced
them again instead of just so it wasn't
really effective way to reduce the
carbonization because it sort of like in
a way encourage certain companies to
continue producing
uh
greenhouse gases
and then removing them from the industry
so it was it wasn't really effective
it's difficult to explain anyway not
good
so
in terms of the quiz
joe is winning i think i know joe
you're the winner of this well done
so
eastern new energy is the project i'm
working on we are
a erdf funded program
we focus on decarbonization so
low and zero carbon actions and local
economic development
and so we also have a research project
that goes along the erdf
funded
delivery which is about
understanding the barriers
that
organizations and communities and
buildings and lives
encounter when trying to decarbonize
so the project goes along with this
research um and our strategies and our
um packages of support
goes and tries to respond to these
barriers
in in terms of the carbonization so
through this we provide support to
organizations that includes sme which is
why i focused on smes in this
presentation
and we provide support such as research
and development or business development
support carbon calculations etc
so along with the university of east
london a range of organizations are
working with us and specializing in
various areas like for example doing
building order audits or
community energy south helping
communities to develop energy supply
systems etc
and this goes more accurately
the
um areas that we cover are here so at
for sure cambridgeshire norfolk suffolk
wentland
and parts of lincolnshire and sex and
i'm really sorry about my french
pronunciation of these areas i try my
best here
and the way we can help smes to reduce
their carbon emissions so we have a cub
knowledge exchange programs that we
organize which are a series of workshops
where smes can join us
and in this workshop we've discussed how
to establish a policy to decarbonize how
to establish a carbon plan
then
our specialist of carbon calculation
tools we'll come and talk about tools
and how to use them
so it's a series of six workshops
helping
smes to establish the carbonization
strategy
and then
we can also help smes and other
organizations to calculate the carbon
emissions in particular we do something
which is a life cycle carbon assessment
so we calculate the carbon emissions of
products so if an organization come and
presents us with a product which they
are developing or even that they're
already selling we can calculate the
carbon emissions of that product and can
be really using useful information we
can also provide advice in some cases on
how to reduce the carbon emissions that
this
product carries
we can also provide support for
organizations to calculate their own
scope 1 2 and 3
carbon emissions
and then
we can help organizations to reduce the
carbon emissions through the eastern new
energy program for example green fleet
strategies or building audits as i was
mentioning earlier
some capital grants are provided through
ini
um we can also help um this is with not
nature-based emissions for carbon
nature-based solutions to reduce carbon
emissions is something that we can help
with
and finally look at circular economy
solutions
i think that's about it i hope that i
didn't run over i haven't really looked
at the time
um do you if you have any questions
perhaps
are you very tired
i'm really sorry for those who didn't
answer with the phone you didn't get the
opportunity to win
thank you thank you
[Applause]
you